it sounds like he's finding common
ground Vox did another healthcare video
relatively recently no that's called the
real reason American healthcare is so
expensive
let me ask you this about Vox question
of the day do you agree with Gerald's
assessment on Vox and that when they
released videos now they just pray to
God that nobody does research but nor
watches this show it's gotten to the
point where they just try to slide it in
there no let me give them credit here
with this and we'll do a point-by-point
rebuttal they actually do offer some
solutions so their argument is this is
why American health care so expensive
and then they do offer usually they just
criticize and kind of like John Oliver
and so we want to give credit where it's
due they found a new bet your elf boy
two offers
yes solution I got a semi Cupid let's go
first clip America's government spending
on health care on programs like Medicaid
and Medicare and the VA our versions of
socialized medicine it's about the same
size as these other countries these
countries where the government runs the
whole health care system no no no okay
this is right off the bat listen same
size they're conflating size and
percentages this is really perfectly not
so the hint the United States total
total cost of health care total spending
on health care or if you want to use GDP
I don't know that that exact chart what
they're using it's very different from
New Zealand or Portugal or Norway yeah
also by the way do you know why it's
different do you know why it's different
because military because Sweden on that
map they need our military to protect
them from anybody benefits from the
United States mo that's why they don't
they don't pay for they don't military
so they can piggyback off of all the
innovation and great cool stuff that we
that's us the land of cool stuff you're
welcome stop conflating percentages in
size let's get into more next clip it's
the private insurance system that makes
health care in America so expensive
conventional wisdom says the government
is more expensive than the private
sector and yet here we are with the
biggest private sector spending the most
why is it free-market so bad I can join
the cost of health care oh here we go
very simple answer because it's not the
markets job to control the cost and this
is something that they do a lot they go
back to just a cost cost the biggest lie
ever told and you see this from Young
Turks and there are these other atheist
channels that are that are more liberal
leaning say what more people are
satisfied with the health care no this
is in this entirely stems from
subjective standards how do you feel
about your health care if you give
someone a a sandwich with flecks of
human feces in it but it's free they'll
probably like that sandwich more than a
sandwich that's fecal matter list but
mediocre at best if somebody paid for so
that's important they're only talking
here about the costs it's not the prep
attackers job to control the cost but to
provide the best services to provide the
most innovation to provide health care
available to many different people all
kinds of different options whether
they're lower cost or higher cost
premium health care services some
examples I think three separate analysis
yeah concluded than 85% of the drugs
approved by the FDA since 1988 arose
solely from research and development
performed in the private industry
Berkeley Berkeley cites that 75% of
clinical trials are privately funded
that doesn't come cheap if your only
standard is why are they spending so
much and you're not taking this into
account you're not going to see the
whole picture and sometimes that's by
design yeah and they start out bashing
the free market like health care is void
of government interference and it's a
free market model that we should look at
to see this with unregulated wild west
yeah come on don't you know people can
just sell you health care industry just
be intellectually honest here in your
first point you can get health care
online without a background check we
don't go to the doctor more than the
Germans and the Japanese in fact to go
to the doctor less the difference
between us and them is it we pay every
time we go to the doctor for everything
from an angioplasty to a hip replacement
from a c-section to a pain reliever in
America the price for the same procedure
at the same hospital
it varies enormous lis depending on who
is footing the bill all right so this is
he knows he keeps coming back to he just
keeps talking about how we pay more this
is important I want you to see a whole
picture okay if you pay more that's only
a portion of any transaction if you go
and purchase anything at a store right
now let's say I go I go and I pay $10
what's your next question for what would
you get for what's the other part there
you go what's the quality
simple look we're paying x4 we're paying
X amount of money and it's too many X's
yeah what for
let's just look at the bill are our
results better than say South Africa
Spain included in the charts or maybe
many of those procedures or drugs get
invented in the private sector the
United States leads in creation of new
jugs jugs in the creation of new drugs
and publications of medical research
different chart service patients are 45%
more likely to die in British hospitals
in the United States now I've talked
about this many times wait times in
Canada for hospital beds they're close
to nine hours the NHS failed to reach
its goal of a four hour wait for our
wait times in the ers what time in the
US it's about two hours so again don't
just look at the one portion of the
equation how much are you spending what
are you getting from what is the rest of
the world getting from privately funded
health care I get it
you don't like paying for stuff everyone
likes free stuff we like the party
favors we like the loot bag but that
does not national health care policy
make next clip the price for someone
with public insurance like Medicare or
Medicaid is often the lowest price these
groups he covers so many people that the
government can demand lower prices from
hospitals and doctors and they get those
lower prices if the doctors in hospitals
say you know there was a ton of business
that's a bad thing that's one third of
doctors now won't accept new net new
Medicaid patients and is getting worse
if you look at the trend fewer and fewer
doctors are accepting Medicaid and
Medicare why because though you just say
if the hospital don't accept it they
won't last just it's like okay this mug
all right it's $69 annually if you're a
student I'll give you 20 yeah but we
can't afford that though it's 60 because
we have server costs we have 12
employees at $69 no I'm gonna give you
20 yeah well no thank you
only the person saying I'm gonna give
you 20 holds a gun to your head says by
the way you're taking 20 that's a good
thing that's why doctors just stopped
working and they don't they say you know
what don't open the door on deck that
guy comes in he always offers me 20 he
only offers you 20 don't let him in
don't let him in next clips won't easily
be found in most hospitals charge
uninsured patients four times as much as
Medicare patients for an ER visit okay
[Laughter]
so one thing no one wants to talk about
this many uninsured people use the ER as
effectively their health care plan right
you can't be refused in emergency right
the last thing to ask for is your health
care and Folie illegal immigrants in the
United States for example go in get care
leave never pay yeah but the difference
is with no social security number right
no credit issues so it's free care so
that's the reason that ers are
incredibly in hospital all these
hospitals are incredibly expensive
compared the cost of services say at an
ER with providers who exclusively and
then it's the United States particularly
I was from Canada I didn't know this
existed yeah deal with like cash only
patients so cash only doctors I have a
CAD
I have a healthcare plan that's
catastrophic care and I go to a cash
doctor okay cash only
MRIs there's a good example I've done
this many times insurance would have
paid two three times the amount for the
MRI that I paid when I went and I paid
for it myself anyway Lex neck Mac next
clip other countries they don't have
this problem instead of every private
insurance company negotiating with every
health care provider there's just this
big list country the central government
they go and they say if you want to sell
to us to all of our people then here's
what you can charge for a checkup
here's what you can charge for an MRI or
a prescription for the limit or and so
then whether that bill goes to the
heavily regulated private insurance
companies in Germany or directly to the
government like the UK sounds best
country is telling the doctor or
hospital or drug company how much that
bill will be and because the government
controls access on all of the customers
it's an offer this hospitals and doctors
and it sounds really bad to see but we
can't refuse Boxter supported
price-fixing even implied that the
practice is mobster like which yes yeah
but it's okay so long as the government
does it scale it up we probably thought
American History X was a family fill
about
the government can step in if they don't
accept Medicaid and curb stomp with
cinema lubes tracks playing in the
background Oh what is this what is this
rate fixing do Farrar I don't know say
doctors well in Canada we just it was
really hard it took years just to get a
family doctor yeah in the UK since
there's a very low ceiling to what they
can make as apparently it's virtuous
according to Vox from 2008 to 2012 more
than 8,000 doctors left the UK and by
the way the only reason that other
countries can price fix on drugs is
because of places that don't allowing
for the innovation the creation of new
drugs let's say the government said hey
hey listen okay alright the price that
people are gonna pay for your new cancer
treatment it can only it's gonna be a
hundred bucks that's it you can't charge
more but it but it it costs billions of
dollars to create don't care that's the
cost that's the offer you can't refuse
guess what the companies that create
research the companies that innovate
they're going to create zero new cancer
treatments there is no incentive to go
in so we burden the cost the private
sector burdens the cost and then these
other countries piggyback off of them
and provide it at a subsidized rate that
doesn't mean that somewhere down the
line somebody didn't invest in creating
new better health care you need that to
keep this afloat just like you need the
United States military to keep Canada
from being invaded from I don't know
anyone next clip under a single-payer
system if you did drive prices down
doctors and hospitals they would be paid
less in there right now they're lining
some of them closed some go out of
business or some move
sounds like a turns out everything we
talked about was completely unnecessary
because our counters well you're gonna
lose doctors hospitals are gonna close
down check hair is going to be worse
offer yes yes yes but here comes
and in that plan he expands Medicare to
cover vision and dental and he opens it
to nearly everyone not just 65 and older
all kids go on Medicare automatically
and most adults can buy in it's a dream
far down overnight but it would at least
begin to recognize what we already know
and what most other countries already do
that health care is one of those things
the government can do cheaper and better
but but you just said none of those
things are true fewer doctors are never
accepting these government forms of
health care Medicaid in particular
Medicare is going to be catching up
really soon the solution here is yeah
hospitals are gonna close in yeah we're
gonna lose doctors but we do know that
if we put everybody onto a system that's
effectively bankrupt and we have to
invade slush funds in order to support
it's gonna work out eventually and it
doesn't work precisely because of like
you said the red tape and the costs
associated with health care it is unreal
to me that they can concede all of the
territory everything that we talked
about in this video and they don't care
anyways because they believe that the
government can somehow do it better than
it's been doing it here's the deal it's
a good it's a good measurement right
you've got Medicare you've got Medicaid
okay yeah we have problems with the
image we have way more problems with
third party insurers then we've had it
then ever before I'll give it to them
yeah what was doing better where do you
where do you have better options right
now we're not doing the thing that they
try and do when they're trying to
obfuscate all of their you know their
their information their facts because
they don't want you to do the research
I'm not saying this is an issue that's
way more nuanced then no listen they're
not showing the complete picture okay
right obviously everything is more
nuanced than you can fit into a video if
it's less than five hours long
everything is more nuanced and you can
fit into a YouTube clip or even onto the
full version of the show what is not
nuanced what does not require subtlety
to understand is that this entire video
only discusses costs it does not discuss
quality of service this is one thing if
you're looking to argue your point if
you're looking to have this conversation
with somebody usually not from a country
that has socialized health care mind you
okay usually people come from socialized
health care they go we'll give you that
one
it's better
year your hotels are like hospitals I
thought I thought it was at a Marriott
turns out I just broken my arm and woken
up on morphine it is nice here compared
to where I was raised in Montreal you
need to when discussing this issue and I
would love to have someone from Vox on
this show to discuss it pin them down on
quality of care and make sure that
quality of care is measured by objective
outcomes and not subjective polls asking
people how do you feel about your
healthcare when you frame that in and
you're okay let's get outside of costs
let's get outside of what people think
about crappy healthcare because they're
not paying for it and I live in
socialized hellholes what are the actual
objective outcomes of healthcare it is a
losing issue for them it's a losing
issue for them internationally it's a
losing issue for Vox domestically if you
actually compare Medicare Medicaid and
the private sector and it sucks you mean
nothing like this video subscribe by
clicking the subscribe button it's
Atkinson it's a circle now it used to be
a square which most buttons aren't
squares let's it's on a phone
there's square buttons on phones what
most buttons are circles you understand
what I'm talking about or watch the
recommended video which is popping up in
a box or subscribe at lateral credit
comm slash mug club join the mud club so
you can get the daily show and that
means that you are not beholden to the
YouTube censoring overlords let's be
honest you like being there where you
are under their thumb power bottom you